nice got here FPS is such a leader in
the field of innovative scholarship it's
really honor for me to be here so thank
you for this invitation I was thinking
but the last time I came here I was a
senior in high school one of the
visiting colleges I came here and that
got me thinking to how I got into this
field in the first place
look let's see if this works hold on a
minute I've air quality engineering
actually it alone story the way I got
into this was from a typo on my college
application I want going to call you
engineering but what I what I really
intend to go into was a different field
which is hair quality engineering now
this is an area where there's tremendous
opportunity for engineers to make a real
difference in the world and this is a
topic I've been passionate about since I
was a kid as evidenced by this picture
here I could really have used some work
there and actually I've been in this for
quite a long time even for my younger
days right there and you can tell I'm a
child of the 70s by the mismatched plaid
it's like bell-bottoms went on turns out
there was not hair quality engineering
needed studies a topic so then I
switched the nearest thing which was air
quality engineering and I'll make that
switch now so thanks for coming I think
if you saw the title of my talk kind of
a natural response would be something
this this is kind of how I respond which
is you know really air pollution kills
is that right I studied this topic and
I'm constantly surprised every day by
how strong are the health effects of air
pollution and so what I want to talk
about today is how we might use that
information about the health effects of
air pollution in setting our air quality
management goals and our air quality
management actions so I'm gonna begin
with just sort of how do we know about
the health effects of air pollution this
is probably a familiar picture to those
of you who work with Michelle Bell and
this is one of the original slides that
are one of the kind of the places that
many people start from which is the
London Fog so this was a a week or two
episode when in London this was in 1952
there may be people here in the audience
who remember this happening and made
news around the world the air pollution
built up and up people using coal for
heating and the air was very stagnant
for a couple weeks and the concentration
is not very high so this is a picture
from midday in London there's all kinds
of wonderful stories from people who
lived through this episode and you know
kind of abandoned their cars in the
streets because the pollution was so
dense they couldn't see where they were
going to
I've heard stories from police officers
who were trying to get around it was so
dark they enlisted help of blind people
help them get around because for those
people who are blind the fact you
couldn't see matter so much there were
enormous health effects from this high
concentration episode interesting ly the
medical community was not the first one
to notice it were the Undertaker's and
the florists because there's such a rise
in in the the mortality rates so here's
some numbers around this people have
reanalyzed this michele has looked this
as well so here's this episode looking
the days of December and you see in gray
this this smog event and so the two
things are measured the time smoke and
sulfur dioxide where the concentrations
went up quite a bit and then you see in
red death rates so I'll notice two
things one is you don't need any
complicated statistics to pull up the
signal from the noise here there's a
several fold increase in mortality rate
during this episode really strong signal
there and the other thing to notice is
that when the episode ends the death
rates don't go back to their original
level right away it actually takes a few
weeks till they come back down to the
original episode so there's a a
short-term effect there's kind of this
intermediate term effect as well so
following from this incident and
incidents like it there are some others
elsewhere in Europe and and some in the
US as well the thinking around air
pollution was we have to avoid these
really high concentration episodes and
if we do that if we keep the
concentrations lower then we'll be safe
and that's what's codified in the Clean
Air Act we have the National ambient air
quality standards the knacks which is
EPA supposed to set the standards that
we if we stay below then we will be safe
and that was a reasonable thinking
following this kind of incident up until
the publication of this article in the
New England Journal of Medicine and this
is the Harvard SiC City study so what
they did is they tracked long-term
health effects of air pollution not the
short term health effects like we just
saw in the in the London example but the
long term health effects so here the
years of follow-up and you see they're
going more than decade and they had six
cities so each city is a separate line
and what you see in the wax this is the
probability of survival so we start off
in Year Zero where the probability of
survival is 100% because a precondition
for enrollment in studies you had to be
alive in the being of the study okay
fair enough and then as the study goes
on this is a large Co
horde of thousands of people people
started dying and what they observed is
that in the dirtier cities the death
rate was higher than the cleaner cities
and that comes out in the slope of this
line and when they plotted that death
rate on the y-axis versus the
concentration so here's a concentration
of fine particles or PM 2.5 particles
that are smaller than two and a half
microns in diameter on this axis is the
death rate ratio - the cleanest City or
normalized to clean of City so the
cleanest city gets a value of one and
everything is ratioed relative to that
there's two things I'll point out about
this finding one is just how straight
that line is it's a really clean clear
relationship shockingly clear how strong
is that relationship between air
pollution and mortality in the Harvard
SiC City study and the second thing
that's really surprising is the value of
these y-axis that you're getting a 10
percent or 20 percent increase in
mortality rates because of the air
pollution concentrations that were there
surprisingly large and actually last one
more thing to point out is remember from
the London smog we thought well if we
just keep the concentrations low enough
then we'll be safe and what you don't
see here this is kind of a straight line
when you don't see as a safe
concentration that shows up more
pollution is worse less pollution is
better but there's no concentration that
we can identify as safe it's all
normalized to the cleanest city here and
then the last bit of background this is
from a project called the global burden
of disease that is an effort by
researchers around the world it's a
major collaboration from probably
hundreds of researchers to catalog what
are the root causes of death and disease
and here I'm showing the death numbers
so this is in mortality in millions per
year and I'll point out the two air
pollution examples up here household air
pollution now the colors are for middle
and low income and high income so this
is mostly an issue in middle and low
income not in high income countries this
is cooking with solid fuels agricultural
waste cow dung coal whatever fuels are
cheap or free leading to very high
concentrations indoors and then ambient
outdoor air pollution or ambient PM
particulate matter you'll see if there's
some blue up there and some parts that
are not blue so this is an issue
globally and it's also an issue in
high-income crunch
and both of these are on top-10 list of
global killer so there are major
attribute contributor to death and
disease globally so if we wanted to
improve upon this these health effects
we were typically track this emissions
to health effects paradigm minute step
back here and take a drink kasumi we're
starting from the emission source going
through concentrations to exposures and
intakes this is a causal chain where we
typically typically track we want to
understand how reductions in emissions
would address these health effects in my
own work I focus here in the middle and
exposure assessment so I use a variety
of methods one is direct measurement
these are some people in Jakarta
Indonesia carrying around a backpack you
can make measurements of air pollution
come back to lab and either way some
filters or download some real-time data
to understand what concentrations people
were exposed to when they went about
their day we use satellite based
estimates there's satellites overhead
and we can get information about air
pollution based on those satellite
measurements and then lastly modeling
there's all kinds of models there's
mechanistic models there's empirical
models what I'm showing here is a type
of model called Elaine use regression
which it has good spatial precision
don't use various models to understand
air pollution concentrations how they
vary in space and in time and for the
mechanistic models how those
concentrations might change if we reduce
the emissions so I'm basically exposures
I want to go upstream in my research and
look at what happens if you change the
emissions has that shift exposures and
then also downstream in this causal
change what would be the changes to
health as a result of shifting those
exposures
so with that here's my outline for today
the three topics I want to talk about
one is urban design how a city is laid
out for example sprawl versus infill
development the size and shape of a city
and how that influences air pollution
and I'll talk about some evidence from
satellites for that the second topic is
indoor pollution in rural India again
from from solid fuel combustion and I
just mentioned how higher the health
effects amount of quite large and there
we're looking at an intervention study
that aims to reduce the emissions and
exposures and the third topic is looking
at transportation biofuels versus fossil
fuels will be air pollution impacts from
from this two different fuel
alternatives a theme throughout all B's
and I'll come to this explicit at the
end is environmental justice who is more
exposed to air pollution who's less
exposed and how would those disparities
shift as we were to increase or decrease
the emissions and so I'll close the talk
with a few comments about environmental
justice explicitly yeah
okay I guess I'd say in a dense
environment
well one metric I look at is intake
fraction what fractions of the emissions
are inhaled in general you want your
heating emissions to go outdoors so the
exposures might be similar if there are
dents in a dense environment if you have
indoor exposures as well or indoor
emissions and that could potentially
increase if you're talking about kind of
a single-family dwelling right and in a
high-rise typically you'd expect it to
be separated from the people so from
that standpoint the the exposure to
those emissions could be broadly similar
you might have very different emissions
in some cases you might be able to emit
from the top of a tall building as
opposed to a ground level and that could
make quite a big difference that's one
potential difference but emissions and
your people is the name of the game and
so if you have emissions in dense urban
environments those are going to be
likely important emissions from the
standpoint of Public Health so let me
talk about this move on to the first one
which is urban design and I'll start
with a picture from my PhD dissertation
I was taking a class in urban design
from Bob Severo and we were learning
about infill development that one of the
kind of mantras of good urban design is
to increase population density in
certain ways and I was studying
exposures and the challenge is if you
put people closer together well the
benefit is that people may drive less
for a lot of reasons they don't have to
get they don't have as far to get to
where they're going there might be more
public transportation there might be
more disincentives to driving like more
congestion or higher parking fees so
there's there's a bunch of reasons why
added density may reduce the vehicle
miles traveled per person per day but
from exposure standpoint by increasing
density you're also putting people in
closer proximity to those now reduced
emissions and so the question is kind of
which which one wins and and this was
some modeling look at that kind of very
very
simple and transparent modeling so
here's my city it's a flat square
everybody drives the same amount
everyone has breathes the same amount of
air pollution and we can look what
happens as we add population and force
them to do infill development or let the
city expand or if the city expands but
at constant density and so what you see
here from doing this kind of analysis
you can represent those changes in your
city as partial derivatives and apply
those partial derivative mass balance
equations and what you get from this
kind of an exercise is if by increasing
density people drive only a little bit
less then you would probably increase
your exposures because you haven't
reduced the emissions enough to
compensate for the added proximity
whereas if by increasing density people
drive a lot less than you can more than
compensate for the added proximity you
might see a net benefit to air pollution
so I was curious after doing this
modeling work what happens empirically
what do we observe and for that I got
into looking at the satellite data data
so we had a database of about 90 cities
shown up here and overlaid in color are
the satellite based estimates of ground
level no.2 air pollution and we have
information about each city such as the
population the GDP per capita and in
these two measures of urban form which
I'll talk more about in the next slide
continuity and compactness and I'll show
some examples of what this means but one
is kind of connectedness and one is
circularity so here's one example city
which is Minneapolis st. Paul where I
live
here's the satellite imagery of the city
here looking at kind of built-up versus
not built-up areas here's the satellite
based estimates of no.2 concentration
and then this is just overlaying these
two to look at where the concentrations
are throughout the city yes sir
sure sure I can put you to our articles
on this in general the satellite does a
pretty good job at picking up spatial
patterns of air pollution so for example
showing that this is the urban area and
this is the rural area it doesn't do a
great job of getting the absolute
concentration but if you need the
relative concentration it does a pretty
good job and that's kind of what we need
here yes sir so for this analysis I'll
get to that when you see the results in
a minute it's mostly no.2 because
there's really good spatial precision
with the saddle the estimates of no.2 we
I'll show us in a minute but we also
look at PM 2.5 and
ozone but the satellite estimates are
based on no.2 so here's an example of
urban form I picked out four cities from
the database showing the variety of
continuity and compactness so continuity
is how contiguous is the built-up growth
and what you'll notice is in the less
contiguous column a greater fraction of
the total land area is outside of the
urban core whereas over here there's
more contiguous growth that means that a
greater fraction of the built-up area is
contiguous with is spatially connected
with that urban core so another way to
say it we how patchy is the growth is
there leapfrog wrote this is kind of
more leapfrog growth and this is more
contiguous growth over here and as I'll
show on the next slide this is the one
ends up being statistics significant
predictor amount of two concentrations
the other metric we looked at is
compactness which is kind of a measure
of circularity so these are more compact
more circular cities and these are less
compact more cigar shaped cities we
found that that's not since its least
significantly associated with an hour to
air pollution so you run these models
these are linear regression models and
you get a results that look kind of like
this so here we have income and you see
this
curved response which is what you'd
expect from the environmental Kuznets
curve if you believe that theory for
urban air pollution that as income
increases air pollution gets worse but
only up to a point and then it kind of
curves over bigger cities have worse air
pollution here's my to urban form
metrics continuity is and one that was
sophistical e significant meaning that
this slope is statistically different
from zero
compactness was not too significant I
mean this is not statistically different
from zero zero to mean there's no impact
of compactness on air pollution and then
die Ellucian rate not surprisingly the
more dilution you have in your city this
is the sort of local meteorology leads
to cleaner air this slide down here this
is a recreation of this one up here but
all I've done is taken the the bottom
half of the data and just drawn a
straight line up and the reason I do
this is this is sort of a theoretical
line of what would happen if if we were
to continue to increase our emissions
per income at the same rate as in the
bottom half of the data and what you see
over here on the right side of the data
these are you know in kind of US cities
or
high-income cities there's an order of
magnitude difference between extending
the slope this theoretical level and
what we actually observe and that order
of magnitude difference is the air
pollution control that we have bought if
the catalytic converters and the
scrubbers and the other technologies we
have that reduce emissions and lead to
this cleaner level even for higher
economic throughput
so we don't have data on geophysical
constraints so I can't say something
directly about that I'm not sure that's
something you can control for you could
say that might be an underlying
mechanism you've got I pathi sighs
that's a mechanism for what we observe
here I mean the standard urban planning
hypothesis would be that if you have
less patchy growth than people have to
drive as far to get to where they're
going and all those other things I
mentioned but you could certainly offer
other explanations certainly if we had
major topography to the level that
changed dilution rates that would show
up here yeah so to put these results
kind of in words a one standard
deviation increase in continuity was
associated with a 24 percent reduction
in no.2 more populous cities tend to
have worse air quality but the no.2
increase associated with a 10% increase
in population may be offset by moderate
by 4% increase in urban continuity so we
use this as kind of among the few
examples of empirical evidence that
urban form can matter in predicting
concentrations about d'Or air pollution
this was for a global database of cities
we also looked at this in the US only
and we have a very different sets of
data for the u.s. so we have census data
to know where people live and set it
based on satellites and we have the EPA
monitors look up air pollution levels
similar study based on different
databases and what we found there is
that increased population density is
correlated with increased concentrations
of the pollutants we looked at PM 2.5
and ozone that's perhaps not surprising
however once you fix the overall average
population density of an urban area
you hold that fixed if you change where
those people live within the city and
our metric here is population sensuality
I mean to what extent to the people who
live near the urban core if you increase
population centrality
more people living near the urban core
that's associated with improvements in
air pollution and the magnitude is large
it's it's larger than I would have
thought it's comparable to if you look
at the variability among cities from
this change in population sensuality
it's comparable to the variability by
meteorology so that suggests that it's
you know an important variable if I
wanted to be more provocative I'd say
well this this is evidence that we could
potentially use shifts in urban form as
a tool to improve their pollution know
if that's true or not but it's certainly
something where I think of and it's it's
certainly not one of the tools that
their quality engineers typically think
about right now I don't have this up
here but another thing we looked at was
how much public transportation was
available and we found that more public
transportation actually led to
improvements in PM 2.5 which is
reassuring finding so these articles are
both out and we're gonna continue to
work in this area so our next steps one
is looking at a larger sample size and
we had about 90 cities globally in a
previous analysis and we are moving
towards a much larger database to kind
of look at some of the several things
you can pick up with a larger database
and then for the us a few things
improved spatial precision and I'll say
more about that on the next slide we
want to look at environmental justice
issues which I'll kind of come to at the
very end we won't include those here and
then panel data so the results they
showed so far we're really
cross-sectional I mean we looked at we'd
like to look at how changes in urban
form over time have been correlated with
changes in air pollution over time so
kind of on this on this goal of improved
spatial precision I'm showing here the
two data sources as I mentioned for our
prior analyses for Minneapolis st. Paul
so one where the satellite data when we
do some modeling to convert the
satellite estimates of column total into
ground level concentrations and the
spatial resolution here is about 10
kilometers by 10 kilometers that's a
finest spatial resolution down here
these are the regulatory monitors we
have three of them and this is a kind of
interpolation of those and you can see
this is a pretty boring picture they
agree reasonably well that's that's good
that means that they're probably picking
up the regional average concentration
but they'll end no information about
spatial variability within
within the city so we wanted to develop
an approach that would let us look at
some of the spatial variability within a
city and this is quite a common tool now
in environmental health is an approach
called land-use regression which uses
observations and the land uses where are
the roads where they elevate what are
the elevations were industrial areas
high and low population density those
sorts of factors to make estimates of
air pollution with high spatial
precision and so what we've done here is
a national land-use regression we
include our satellite based estimates
and that's that's quite convenient
because they provide spatially uniform
coverage we also use the EPA monitors
and that kind of folds into developing
land aggression and that lets us make
spatially precise predictions of no2 air
pollution at ground level our estimates
are about point one kilometre spatial
resolution the map you're seeing right
here is we have estimates for each
census block in the US that's it census
block is a smallest spatial delineation
that census does I'm showing one city
over here Minneapolis st. Paul I'm on
our estimates by census block and then
just a line that I drew arbitrarily
across the city and we look up
concentrations as you go across and we
can see is we get the urban or rural
gradients and then there's you know each
time that line passes a road or a park
or whatever this kind of jogs up and
down so it performs the way we expect
I guess I'd say overall the model
performs better than I might have
expected
we've poked and prodded at this model in
various ways to see how well performs we
hold aside some data and build the model
and other data and there's various ways
of testing it and it seems relatively
robust to the different ways that we've
constrained the model and tried to test
it and so we think this is a reasonably
reliable estimate a model to estimate
with good spatial precision and o2
concentrations throughout the US I'll
come back to this at the end of my talk
to talk about informal justice with that
let me move on to the indoor air
pollution aspect and discord the
statistic I showed the numbers globally
here's a number for India specifically
and then about 500,000 deaths per year
our tribute to biomass use in India it's
an enormous enormous number obviously
it's about 5% of the national burden of
disease
and we like many people wondered what
can we do about that and so we have a
cookstove intervention study that we
that we carried out in southern India in
Karnataka we're looking at a specific
stove which is called a Toluca you know
it's a rocket stove so this is a picture
of the new stove here's a kind of
traditional stove what we call a
three-stone fire so there's in this case
kind of three knobs very convenient this
goes back to cavemen times it's very
easy any expensive that wood the wood
goes underneath there's a wide opening
here and in this intervention the
traditional stove was removed in this
case you can see the hearth was
completely removed and broken and a new
hearth was placed and it has this space
where the new stove can sit in there so
here's that you look at manufacturing in
Bangalore
it's an enclosed stove it's not as open
that's a traditional stove there's this
heat shield here there's also a great
that the wood sits on so the air can get
in underneath the wood so you have
higher fuel efficiency meaning it more
energy per kilogram of wood and you have
higher thermal transfer efficiency so
more of the energy generated goes into
your pot when you bring these stoves
into the lab they look great and we're I
have some statistics up there top the
thermal efficiency is about three times
higher in the lab for the new the new
stove that you look over so the
traditional stove and you save quite a
bit of wood to folding trees and we were
curious how this looked in the field so
we went to India we did a randomized
control trial in the field we went to
one village in northern Karnataka
there were about 200 households in the
village we did measurements in all the
households of some health attributes
like blood pressure
we measured indoors and outdoors and we
measured in plume so we can get some
emissions estimates and then randomly
half of the households got the new
stoves we left them there for a couple
months for people to get used to the
stoves and we came back and measured in
all of the households the households
that got the stoves and the household
that didn't get the stoves it's really
important to measure in the households
that didn't get the stoves also because
they are our controls they're our mental
model for what would have happened had
the inter-mountain
intervention household not receive their
intervention so here's just a picture
from the field there's two boxes in this
bottom box you can see there's a line
that goes up and this goes up to the
chimney so we're measuring directly the
plume plume with his bottom box all of
our air pollution equipment is inside
here and this one here has just an inlet
valve kind of a breathing height to
measure what people will be breathing as
they're cooking there's a there's a mesh
kind of covering this Inlet to prevent
insects from getting in we learn the
need for that one the hard way and you
know I'll just mention these are
challenging measurements to make in
rural India there's no hardware stores
nearby there's the the conditions are
hot and dusty and bumpy and that's hard
on the equipment and it's hard on the
researchers who are there to make
measurements pre sun-up Pradhan when
people are doing cooking I'm in late at
night we people come back to the fields
and do cooking so these measurements are
hard fought and hard won each piece of
data is worth quite a bit we ran into a
bunch of issues that we didn't expect
when we out there and one of them is is
shown in this picture and even paying if
you've been paying attention to the
study design I mentioned you might be
looking this picture and saying I can
ask you what's wrong with this picture
we should not be able to have taken this
picture and I'm a how many of you can
identify this but you might be asking
yourself well is this is this an
intervention or a non intervention
household really all the households this
is this is after the intervention they
should either have one kind of stove or
the other kind of stove and this is a
household that has both kinds of stoves
the new stove on the left and the
traditional stove on the right and we're
working with an NGO that's a pretty good
NGO they're in this community on a near
day
basis they're doing the study they're
collaborating with people's mouths a
team India they're telling the people
please follow the protocol you're in the
intervention household please use a new
stove only not the old stove but here's
a household that despite this request
from the NGO has still elected to have
their old stove well any any guesses as
to why this is and those people in the
audience who study this topic on the new
stove is more efficient it burns hotter
which is good for some foods and not for
others and in this community it's great
for cooking rice and vegetables but
people have roti flatbread with every
meal and many people found it
challenging to cook the roti on the
hotter stove without burning it and so
many people elected to go to get the old
so back then you have two burners this
is no different than you or I right so
in your household when you got a
microwave oven you probably didn't throw
away your range-top oven and then you
got a toaster oven and a coffee pod and
a waffle iron and whatever else in your
kitchens with each new technology you
didn't throw away the old technologies
each satisfy common niche cooking need
and it partially adds to and partially
substitutes for the cooking energy
demand you had from your old
technologies the same thing is happening
here
the newer stove is run a little bit
differently in this case it runs hotter
and so people would rather have these
two technologies which serve different
niche needs instead of having this one
yeah yeah so we don't have a picture of
it it varied so in some cases there's
zero chimney it's just just to the
inside room in this one actually in both
of these pictures this picture yeah so
this pressure you can kind of see it but
those stoves are set in a little bit and
it's kind of over a hood like you kind
of imagine like an old-style
fireplace in many of the quaint Yale
buildings right they're sort of this
large fireplace where you could almost
step in yeah so is it there is kind of a
hood chimney so I'd say there's a range
from some have no chimneys and some have
a mild hood you know a little bit the
vents up and some have a pretty good
hood and the and the fire is in it so
that certainly not all the smoke
but a fair bit would go up the chimney
you have variation in that yeah
absolutely
we had another of other issues that we
ran into I'd be happy to talk about that
we didn't expect that we learned by
doing this in the field which we would
not have learned just by using these
stoves in the lab so we went into this
thinking we had two kinds of
subpopulations the cases and the
controls and it turns out that have
three subpopulations the non
intervention and the intervention who
followed protocol in the intervention
who did not follow protocol
so we're still analyzing these data but
but here's some early results looking at
PM 2.5 on the left and black carbon on
the right in in these block box pots so
the bottom is the 10th percentile the
25th percentile the 50th percentile the
median 75th and 90th and the Diamonds
are the mean value and what you can see
is if you go from the controls to the
well actually we do the black carbon
first because that's easiest these are
not statistically different so we're not
see a big change in black carbon that's
an easier story on this side going from
the controls to choo choo cos we do see
a statistically piant drop in average
concentration you'll see that Oh among
these plots the interquartile range is
changes a bit not a lot a lot of the
bigger change is in the half of the data
which is outside of the interquartile
range so here seeing this kind of lower
tail this these are changes in
concentration post minus pre so we would
love to see all these concentrations be
below zero meaning and improvement in
concentrations many of these are above
zero meaning increase in concentrations
and and that includes our controls so in
many of the control households
concentrations were higher after than
before who knows why there could be any
number of reasons maybe the wood was
wetter in the next season when we came
back maybe there were more festivals
maybe food was more plentiful there
could be a near infinite list of
possible explanations that's why we have
to have the controls to see that's again
it says our mental model what would have
happened had we not done the
intervention and so even though here the
average concentration went up if this is
greater than zero it didn't go up as
much as in the controls and so I would
look at that and claim well that's
probably a success on the part of the
intervention
yes yes sure right
you have different combustion conditions
I mean the the what fraction of the
particles are elemental carbon or a
black carbon will vary depending on the
combustion conditions one anecdote we
heard a lot and I don't have specific
data on this but we heard this
anecdotally meant too many times was
people say with the old fire you could
just sort of put a bunch of wood in and
go about and do some other things then
come back two minutes later and push the
wood in and then go away where it's been
a new one it goes through the what a lot
faster is a really narrow opening so you
can only put a few a small number of
pieces of wood in there and they go
faster so you have to kind of stay there
a little more and feed them in so it's
just different combustion conditions we
expect black carbon you know may very
differently from PM if we combine the
two to look on the mix stoves
populations which would become an intent
to treat analysis we still get a
statistically significant reduction it's
not quite as statistics mean I think we
have our p value is 0.7 instead of point
O three so this points out that you know
a really important factor is whether
people follow protocol now I mentioned
that this NGO is in the community on a
near-daily basis so in this particular
intervention
you know these we had roughly a third or
so in this group relative of the total
population
I would imagine a different intervention
we might not have quite as many people
following protocol if they're NGOs not
quite as engaged as we had here yeah
the couldn't the prior intervention was
in our fall so September October
November and the post intervention was
kind of our late spring mmm yeah April
May yeah right so this is in northern
Karnataka my understanding so it's not
really a need for heating in this
particular village the study that Bob
and I are doing when I go back to this
part of India and then also go to the
north to Kulu Valley where there
definitely is a heating and a cooling
season but that would absolutely play a
role my understanding is it doesn't hear
there's not really heating yeah yeah
yeah I mean from talking to people of
course you know most people don't care
about the health impacts the villagers
have we talk to but they do care about
the smoke and so if we're going to say
well this Stover you're having a chimney
should reduce the smoke that's an
irritant they would be perfectly happy
to reduce mouth smoke yeah
right that's a concern we don't have any
data on that I mean you know they're
kind of if as they move out most of
these are one or two room households and
so actually observing how close are they
to the fire for a percentage of the time
would be a great research project and we
don't have data on that I mean I'm not
sure if you could really ask a person
that of an aunt totally what their
memory is but you got a huge bias of
what they think the right answer is you
could measure but we didn't kind of put
a tracer on them so you know I guess I'm
continue to work on this it's an
important topic from the standpoint of
global health I don't feel like we've
cracked this nut I'm not really sure
what the solutions are there are some
stoves out there that may reduce
emissions you know we've done one study
and there are other studies out there
and okay so our sample size is um you
know 100 200 households but really our
sample size is one village and we ran
into certain issues in this one village
but I'd love to see this kind of study
happen in ten other villages because
we'll probably run into ten other issues
in those other villages as we implant
these stoves or kind of a next stoves
that are promised to Philips fans to
over other ones that are out there but
it's pretty clear what we see in the lab
is really different for what happens in
the field we get all kinds of surprises
in the field so that we move on to the
third topic which is on biofuels and of
course we have a lot of societal
benefits from transportation I think the
chance to come here do you have a yes
which is great for me and there are all
kinds of there's some downsides to
transportation as well and for that
reason many people are searching for
alternatives to the petroleum that runs
much of our transportation
infrastructure here's some estimates
just to put some numbers nice for mark
delucci estimating that the air
pollution and human health impacts from
transportation are among the dominant
externalities from transportation
meaning impacts that are not included in
the market transactions for consuming
transportation on the order of hundreds
of billions of dollars per year from
transportation in the u.s. we also have
a goal in the u.s. of environmental
justice and here let me just read this
quote this is from an executive order
that Bill Clinton signed
quite a while ago now saying and I just
read the part of blue that each federal
agency shall make achieving
environmental justice part of its
mission this is something that we're
tasked our federal government is tasked
with doing and I think that's remained
an unmet challenge so far it's something
that we're still trying to figure out
how should our federal agencies try to
address this executive order so you know
overall we're trying to pose the
question our biofuels and other
alternative fuels better for society
than the fossil fuels which they would
displace that's the big-picture question
and we're looking at the air pollution
aspects of that because that seems to be
a really important part of that bigger
picture so we have a number of possible
alternatives we have grid independent
gasoline-electric hybrid vehicles like
the Priya the non plug-in Prius we have
compressed natural gas diesel vehicles
ethanol vehicles or e 10 vehicles that
are using ethanol from corn grain which
is how we get our ethanol currently and
come next generation corn stover it's
over is the part of the corn that's left
over after you take away the cobs on the
outside it's currently what's left over
that's kind of the idea for next
generation biofuels these corn stover
ethanol and then electric vehicles and
of course it depends on where you get
the electricity from so the u.s. grid
average coal natural gas corn stover you
can Co fire corn stover
in coal electricity generation uh-oh
oh here we go I've got a lecture now
thanks
and then the last electricity is wind
wave or solar power kind of a renewable
energy so again we're and go back this
causal chain we track the emissions the
exposures and the health effects in this
case we also have a life cycle analysis
so we're looking not only at the
tailpipe emissions but all the way
upstream so if you produce the biofuel
requires growing the crops you have to
run tractors which requires diesel fuel
you need fertilizers which take
electricity to generate and so on we're
looking back up the supply chain for the
biofuels and also for the petroleum
fuels to refine those fuels what that
means in practice is we have literally
hundreds of different processes that are
involved in these fuel life cycles and
for each one we need spatial
disaggregation to know where those
emissions occurred so here I'm showing
three of the processes one of the
vehicle tailpipes so here's a map of the
US and you can see that we spatially
Aggie especially this tire at those or
allocate those to where the tailpipes
are which is the cities and the major
roadways we also have to temporally
decide rate these to run and air
dispersion models so we have by month of
year and by time of day when we think
these emissions happen there's also some
chemical disaggregation I'm not getting
into here okay so two other ones
fertilizer nitrification so this is kind
of where the fertilizers would be
applied and when impact the environment
where those emissions are and then coal
mining and coal cleaning which happens
at the sites are here this is where the
coal mines are and where the emissions
would occur from these so we have for
each of these processes upstream where
those emissions happen and then we we
use those emissions in an air dispersion
model and I'll show you two results
today one is for national modeling that
we've done so here's here's our domain
these are 12 kilometer by 12 kilometer
grid cells which for this kind of
dispersion model this is an oil Arian
grid model that's pretty spatially
precise for this kind of national domain
and we simulate a whole year and then
I'm also gonna show results from one
nested grid we've done in Southern
California so we zoom in here to 2
kilometer by 2 kilometer grid cells so
the prior example would be the national
impacts of national fuel policies and
this one would be the local impacts of
national fuel policies
so have an animation
so this is what this looks like in the
air dispersion model we have our base
case in the upper left this is national
and emissions inventory we're simulating
a whole year and then for each of these
scenarios we say there's a 10% increase
in vehicle miles traveled what would
happen if the 10% were met by each of
these different technologies and here
I'm just showing the same technologies
even you saw previously you'll notice
the ones in red are electric vehicles
from coal and corn ethanol and the
cleanest one is wind wave and solar
electric vehicles and then we run the
same thing for Los Angeles now the
biggest difference you'll notice here is
that for Los Angeles what really shows
up where the scenarios with tailpipe
emissions the scenarios with electric
vehicles there's not much of a
difference I mean there's some impact
cuz you have the whole kind of life
cycle there's things you have to do
there's transportation whatnot it's not
zero but most of electricity generation
happens outside of this air basin so
it's not that much of a difference
locally from the electric vehicle
scenarios it's really the tailpipe
emissions that we see
so here are the angle average values
again the ones that light up are
electric vehicles from coal electric
vehicles methanol I'm sorry this is cut
off enough there's a way to adjust the
screen size the person who's taping are
you able to adjust the screen size so
that no okay
alright here's what it is there's some
blue here with corn with Stover ethanol
because there's co products in the
production of ethanol and and you can
use that to offset electricity
generation and so we use that as
negative emissions from the electric
grid so we're kind of properly
accounting for the co products that come
from solar ethanol and then again here's
from Southern California and what you
really see the difference is amongst the
tailpipe emissions so let me convert
these scenarios into risks each dot up
here is one of the scenarios one of the
fuel options on the x axis here is
overall population risk so we're looking
at PM 2.5 and ozone from all these
scenarios on the y-axis the label that's
cut off is the difference between
low-income non-white and high-income
white risks so if you have dots that are
above zero that would be sort of the
conventional environmental justice issue
that I mean that low-income non-whites
have higher exposures than do
high-income whites so this is kind of
conventional American justice
and this would be served Reverse
environment justice it's the opposite of
what you might expect so what we see for
example here's gasoline now gasoline
there's some that some of our comparison
because right now most cars use gasoline
and so everything we would compare
against gasoline what you see is there
some scenarios that on the x-axis the
overall population risk some of the
scenarios do worse than gasoline that
includes electric vehicles from coal
which is our worst scenario that's
consistent with the maps that I showed
electric vehicles the overall average
which uses quite a lot of coal and corn
grain ethanol again those ones that
stood out in red on the maps I showed
and then electric vehicles from wind
wave and solar is the cleanest one so
those are the x-axis values in terms of
the y-axis values you'll notice that
gasoline has the highest value it's up
there so the environmental justice
concerns we might say from from this
crime analysis are the highest for
gasoline the other fuels
have lower disparities that is lower in
bio injustice concerns and then you get
this case of coal which is down it's
kind of strongly negative because coal
is rural so the in this map I'm
combining or this plot I'm combining
race and income and of course we can
disaggregate that and let me do that
just to illustrate coal so here is low
income minus high income risk and all be
thoughts line up a much closer to the
zero line so that suggests that what's
really dominating this is racial
differences and not income differences
and here we have differences by race
only you see quite a spread on the
y-axis so it's really race that's that's
driving what you see up here when you
combine them now the coal case is sort
of interesting because they're pretty
rural those rural emissions on average
overall in aggregate are
whites and toward low income those are
the rural exposures and so here when you
look at income and you get kind of this
coal is above the line so it's more it's
exposing more none any lower income then
higher income and we look at race it's
more to White's than Tom whites and then
in the aggregate you get coal which is
sort of below this is zero line we did
the same map for Los Angeles and in that
in that configuration all the electric
vehicle scenarios are kind of in this
one clump because there's not much of a
difference amongst them and they're kind
of near the zero zero point not add it
but they're much closer to it and what
you see is kind of amongst the non
electric vehicles the vehicles that have
tailpipe emissions there's a greater
disparity again gasoline has the highest
disparity the highest environmental
justice concern based on this metric so
let me turn then just this environment
justice issue which is looking at who's
breathing more air pollution who's
breathing less air pollution these are
some results we have from Southern
California just to illustrate this we're
looking at the four different
subpopulations that were in the census
they're White's Hispanics African
Americans and Asians and Pacific
Islanders and for each sub population
here looking at the median intake this
would be what saying in mass per day or
mass per year relative to the overall
population median and these are three
pollutants ozone and white diesel
particles and Benjamin
and we can see as differences amongst
pollutants and differences among
subpopulations so for these two
pollutants diesel and benzene White's
have lower exposures and non-whites have
higher exposures and for ozone the
reverse holds for ozone whites have
higher exposures and non-whites have
lower exposures why you guys study air
pollution why might that be don't be shy
yeah yeah so why is that why is it show
this difference that's exactly right
ozone is a
I mostly agree with that I think if you
don't have a trees in the suburbs you
still have the ozone but it's there but
it's absolutely it's in the right
direction which is these two pollutants
are primary pollutants meaning there are
made it directly so the high
concentrations are downtown and near
roadways and ozone is a secondary
pollutant it forms in the atmosphere it
takes a while for those chemical
reactions to occur from the precursor
missions the high concentrations are not
near the sources not downtown and not
near roadways and that's where you have
more whites and fewer non-whites so
these differences are exactly what you'd
expect from the the spatial patterns of
where people live and where these
pollutants are higher or lower
concentrations this is for one urban
area and there been several studies
documenting this kind of impact for
specific urban areas we've also looked
across the whole u.s. so I'm returning
to this land regression model which let
it let us look University across the
u.s. at all urban areas and rural areas
and so I'm showing here is the average
household income on this level I'm an o2
concentration for whites and non-whites
in large urban areas medium urban areas
and small urban areas
I've probably got another warning I'm
supposed to get my lecture here let's
see if I can turn this off I apologize
for
interestingly when you combine all the
urban areas it's you get a confusing
picture you-you-you don't get much of a
pattern by income because people who are
very affluent are more likely to live in
high in large urban areas than in small
urban areas so to see this kind of a
picture you have that you have to
separate out the large small medium and
small urban areas in the large urban
areas race and income are equal in
importance in predicting concentrations
and in the medium excuse me I'm starting
the large urban area race is more
important than income whereas for these
two urban areas race and income are
about equally important so for this last
but I want to make an argument that
these are kind of four metrics that we
should care about in air quality
management if we're trying to reduce
emissions to address air pollution
here's four things we should care about
one is the impact the total health
impact and a metric call you so that is
mean intake how much pollution are
people inhaling another topic is
efficiency you want to go after the
sources that matter most from the
standpoint of air pollution exposure and
health and the metric I'll use there is
intake fraction what fraction of
emissions are inhaled all else being
equal you'd want to target the sources
with a higher intake fraction than with
the lowest intake with the lower intake
fraction in order to get a larger
exposure and health benefit permission
reduction the third topic is equality no
environmental equality and environmental
justice are often used interchangeably
but they get at different issues
equality is a more mathematical concept
there are metrics that describe
deviations from perfect equality meaning
we all breathe the same amount so this
things like the Gini coefficient and the
Atkinson coefficient which is what I'll
use here and there's other coefficients
for how disparate are the exposures but
that doesn't get at who's breathing more
pollution who's reading less pollution
and so for that come environmental
justice aspect here I look at high
socioeconomic status versus low
socioeconomic status and I'll continue
using low-income non-whites versus
high-income whites to get at that
disparity among demographic attributes
and I have a few slides on what we can
do with these four metrics but but the
main point is that we should care about
all four if we're trying to target the
sources that matter most we should be
concerned with all four of these metrics
and seek opportunities to address
emissions that do a good job for all
four of these so one example we can do
is make maps across the US so here's a
map of two of those for the equity and
the justice and we could use this kind
of map to target you know if we're a PA
where are the environmental justice
issues largest or smallest again that
kind of issue has been investigated had
an urban scale so kind of one city at a
time much more in the literature but
looking comprehensively across the u.s.
at where are the disparities higher or
lower where's the inequality higher or
lower it's kind of a new tool and one I
think we should be looking at for how
can our National Environment justice
policy rationally focus on the areas in
that or most we can also zoom in on a
specific city so these are maps from Los
Angeles so the ocean is over here on the
left the land is over here downtown Los
Angeles Orange County is here and what
we've done here is look at if we reduce
the emissions in certain areas
throughout this throughout this region
what would be the changes in my four
metrics so the areas in red for example
in justice and equality red and orange
would be improvements in those metrics
or reductions improvement in those
metrics and green and yellow would be
dis benefits to those metrics so with
these four maps we can then overlay
those four maps and then the red spots
so here each of those four things have
different lines and then we've doubled
up with NCO lines where it matters more
this gray low-emissions is where the
emissions are near zero so I kind of
read them into it so we don't consider
them and the area in red is the area
where all four of those metrics do
especially well that area in red is
about the tenth the size of the London
low emission zone so that floats the
policy idea that we could focus on these
areas spatially for where are the
emissions that have the biggest impact
in terms of those four metrics I talked
about
so this is a spatial analysis we've done
a similar analysis looking at specific
emission sources so here we have on-road
this is these are diesel particles on
road trains ships off-road and
stationary sources many kind of
industrial sources and how would a a
reduction in emissions affect your
equality and your justice metric and it
turns out it matters whether you frame
this in terms of an absolute shift in
emissions or relative shift in emissions
so this is for it for let's say a 10%
reduction and this is per ton per day
reduction and whether it's relative or
absolute reductions in emissions you see
things slightly differently but the
quadrant you'd want to be in is up here
where you have improvements to equality
and improvements to justice and so this
is based on a similar line of thinking
as the map I just showed the map is
purely the spatial areas this is five
different sources that have different
spatial signatures to where their
emissions are and so we can use this
kind of analysis to make the same
argument which sources should we target
we should target the sources whose
emission reductions would make the
biggest improvements in those four
metrics so I'll stop there
again just I'll end where I started my
focus is on measuring and modeling
exposures looking at where those
exposures come from what would happen if
we increased or reduce those emissions
and what would be the exposure and
health impacts of those shifts where's
the feel of air pollution going you know
where is their quality going I guess
I'll close with one note that air
quality in the US has gotten better over
the long term and I think there's
reasonable space for optimism to work in
this field that's one thing I like about
this field then 1970 when the Clean Air
Act was passed air pollution was much
much worse than it is today essentially
we can get smarter than this problem
faster than it gets worse and faster
than we grow our economies that's what
the evidence suggests from the US in the
long term if you have a long term
perspective there's lots more issues to
work on there's all kinds of new
pollutants we have to focus on that we
know about before and there's all kinds
of issues working on globally retaining
gold
to have instead of a local perspective
but I think there is a reason for
long-term optimism in this field that's
one thing I've liked about studying this
area is the use of this kind of added
knowledge to address these problems so
thank you very much for your attention
let me thank my co-authors and and
collaborators and graduate students who
did all the heavy lifting involved in
the results I just showed and I'll in
there thanks